Kenji of simplesanshin.com here...
...and I'm going to talk about the notes of the sanshin.
And I'll try to keep this video short...
...because I like short videos, so let's get started.
The first thing you want to do is get your sanshin into hon choshi.
That's about right.
This is do, fa, do or C, F, C, for people who like to know those notes,...
...and these are the notes in Japanese.
It's ai, otsu, ro, shi, jo, chu, shaku, ko.
And if you didn't catch that,...
...that's just simply do, re, mi, fa, so, la, ti, do,...
...which is also just C, D, E, F, G, A, B, C.
And if you can figure that out,...
...then you should be able to use an electric tuner...
...or maybe by ear, and you can figure out where to...
...mark your sanshin if that's what you want to do.
This one doesn't have any markings, but this sanshin does.
It's here.
You don't have to worry about some of these but...
Yeah, and use an electric tuner, pinpoint where the notes are,...
...and you're on your way.